here now senior foreign policy adviser
of the trump administration kristin
whiten all right so is this an invasion
is this really what this is the
peacekeeping forces
you know it's really it's certainly not
peacekeeping it's not really an invasion
or if it was it is an invasion it just
happened in 2014. these two territories
in the region of donbass the small part
of eastern ukraine uh were invaded in
2014 by little green men which were
basically russian army troops who had
taken off their insignia but we're still
you know driving russian tanks and
armored vehicles and uh you know two
minutes earlier had been in the russian
army and now uh you know they're just
sort of making it formal all right so
it's a costume change and they've just
rebranded his peacekeeping troops
and the biden administration doesn't
consider this a new development they're
gonna wait and
maybe have a meeting or two scratch
their chins and
perhaps slap some sanctions on tomorrow
morning
yeah the messaging has been so weird
because it's been so stark so
unconditioned you know biden just saying
putin has made the decision to invade
because of our intelligence which
certainly has never been wrong in the
past and so to say that this is coming
and now when you know putin actually
does make a move that deals with
something across the border not in
russia proper uh that you know
uh biden earlier said that well there
might be a minor incursion it would be
no no big deal um it it just goes to the
sort of imprecision cluelessness that
biden has been through all along
incidentally never has he ever explained
what u.s interests really are on the
line here he has it and he's not
prepared the country for what's at stake
in terms of energy prices i mean we're
going to get hammered that's going to
make inflation worse he hasn't told us
what that's all about and uh we're
waiting mr president explain it
christian thank you so much
thank you jesse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else